français alors jean jacques vous allez
maintenant nous parler d'un groupe qui
s'appelle les béruriers noirs
c'est un groupe très particulier qui a
beaucoup de succès auprès des lycéens
ils sont très nombreux à venir ici j'ai
regardé les tranches d'âge parce qu'on
s'est livré une petite enquête
au printemps de son surtout des jeunes
de 12 à 18 ans acquis 18 25 ans donc ça
c'est quand même bon alors les béruriers
noirs cinq groupes de rock loufdingue
complètement
c'est un des premiers groupes français à
vendre correctement alors qu'ils sont
sur label indépendant
ils ont beaucoup circulé ils n'ont pas
fait de promotion médiatique et pourtant
ils ont fidélisé un public et on les a
rencontrés
alors on regarde votre repas
vendredi soir sur le thème joyeux
merdier c'était le titre du programme la
salle du pavillon recevait les béruriers
noirs marsupilami hystérique du rock
punk comme il était dit dans le
programme du printemps ou catalogué
underground et pipelettes commence à
peser
maintenant j'ai eu du mal à me procurer
le dernier 45 tours à faut dire que ces
deux länder ground ainsi carrément
radical on trouve ça que dans les petits
trucs sous le manteau est encore amené
d'issac c'est pas vrai les virus et un
truc qui pourrait être vendu en centre
commercial à 30 valent pour tout le
monde
seulement il se trouve qu'on n'est pas
aidé parce qu'on est dû
soldes
départ à 18 fidèles qu'ils ont conquis
sans promotion médiatique il regrette le
manque de moyens car il aimerait faire
mieux
des gens qui veulent voir les verrues
parce que c'est mal distribué parce que
c'est pas télévisée parce que ceci parce
que cela est il des places ils font des
bornes on doit les respecter
des fois y'a pas de conditions
acceptables pour rejouer mais on le fait
par rapport à ce respect là mais un
appentis adeptes de la dérision de la
partie des attaques passent oncologie
tendance rock la bêtise le racisme et
l'intolérance
quand par exemple on a fait le commando
ferme pernaut ce qui est marrant c'est
une chanson qui soit un peu des gentils
qu'ils voient ça c'est marrant c'est
qu'on dit ça devant une ride mec bourré
je reste
je
pour moi vos pouces et une grosse farce
et puis un truc complètement débile et
moi j'ai même l'impression parodier les
textes des bérus tu veux y aller vers
eux qu'il faut leur texte et puis un
autre 7 à l'écart qui font les pune qui
parodie ce que les érudits pour qu'en
fait que fois pas seulement due allez
les mecs de la révolution fait quelque
chose en plus
étalez les béruriers noirs ont décidé de
frapper un grand coup dans le monde du
rock en faisant grève à partir du mois
de juin
le groupe réclame les moyens de ses
ambitions
avis aux professionnels